Speaker 1: Donald trump jr. Who is just
desperate for his father to like him, just
desperate for his father to like him. He posted
what are essentially dick pics of his dad. The.
Look at this image we're putting up on the screen
for you. And no, it's not X-rated. Sort of,
I guess, like making fun of the redactions in
the affidavit that was released related to the
raid on Mar a Lago. Junior put out on Instagram
an image of an obese Trump on the golf course
with a redaction over what would be very large
genitals, suggesting that you would need such a
redaction if Trump's pants were off. I mean,
listen to what these people are doing to the
country. They're laughing at us around the world.
In his desperation for his dad to like him, Don Jr
did a fake dick pic meme suggesting his dad is
extraordinarily well-endowed. With the tagline
Redact this and the way that this is written
up in different news outlets. It's nobody even
knows how to cover this stuff. Donald Trump Jr
posts obscene meme about his father's crotch.
Junior responded to the release of the
heavily redacted affidavit that provided
justification for the search of Mar a Lago
by posting a meme on his Instagram of Trump
with a comically large black bar over his crotch.
Speaker 2: Redact shots. Trump
Jr captioned the photo.
Speaker 1: Oh my God. The meme follows
similarly solicitous comments from Arizona's
Republican gubernatorial candidate Carrie Lake,
who recently said that Trump and DeSantis have
bd also known as Big D. I have to be careful
for our radio affiliates Big D energy. Trump
made the same claim about his own genitalia
during a 2016 Republican primary debate when Rubio
made a crack about the size of Trump's hands.
Stormy Daniels reports Trump has an unusual
penis. Guys, what the hell is happening? A
Huffington Post Don Junior posts a quote dick pic
of dad after affidavit release quote redacted this
always the intellectual. Donald Trump Jr on Friday
came up with an innovative way to respond to the
public release of the affidavit, posted a picture
of Trump in his golf duds with a long black bar
over his crotch. This is listen, folks. The right
loves to say, isn't this great? These are just
like normal people like me and you. Most normal
people wouldn't do this. A lot of people, if they
were posting this type of stuff, they might lose
their job. So it's actually very much not like
you and me, at least I've never posted pictures
like this to the Internet, let me put it that way.
So that's the latest there. Just an incredible,
incredible, incredible, humiliating situation.